MARTIN: Hey, Josh, where
did you get that lollipop?
JOSH: Oh, hi, Martin.
The Slip Slap Candy
Company came by
and asked for help
connecting their code
to a Google spreadsheet.
I told them, we might
have something for you.
MARTIN: Sounds great!
Stay tuned if you
want to know more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOSH: I met with Max from
Slip Slap Candy Company.
He explained that many
of their internal systems
need to know what ingredients
they have in their warehouse.
MARTIN: It turns out,
the warehouse staff
already keeps track of
this in a Google Sheet.
That's great news, because it's
easy to read a Google Sheet
from Google Cloud Platform.
JOSH: Max didn't want to
deal with server setup
and maintenance, so
he went serverless
and picked Cloud Run.
And he has previous
experience in JavaScript.
So we decided to
use Node.js together
with the Express web framework.
MARTIN: Cloud Run code executes
as a default identity--
the compute default
service account.
Max opened the
warehouse spreadsheet,
clicked the Share button, and
gave that account view access
to the spreadsheet.
JOSH: Then he enabled the Sheets
API in Slip Slap's GCP project.
MARTIN: Max designed
a really simple REST
API with only one endpoint.
If you hit slash
Ingredient ID, you
will get the warehouse
details for that ingredient.
JOSH: The Express
Library makes it
easy to pick up the ingredient
ID and take action on it.
MARTIN: Once Max has
the ingredient ID,
he can call the
getIngredient function
and return that ingredient
to the caller in JSON form.
JOSH: The code for reading
from the Google Sheet
is in the
getIngredient function.
It creates an auth object
with a spreadsheet scope.
It then reads columns A
through E for all rows that
have any data.
Notice how there are
no passwords, keys,
or oauth secrets.
The account running this code
already has read-only access
to the sheet.
MARTIN: Once the Sheets
API returns the rows
from the sheet, Max can loop
over them, find the ingredient
with the right ID, and
return that ingredient's data
to the calling function.
Check the video description
below for the link
to the full code example.
JOSH: This code reads
all rows in the sheet
every time the
REST API is called.
That's OK for a small
sheet like this.
Slip Slap only has about 1,000
ingredients in their sheet.
If you have a much
larger data set,
you should use a
regular database,
like Cloud Firestore
or Cloud SQL.
MARTIN: As the warehouse
staff updates the spreadsheet,
the REST API will always
return the latest data.
Max loves this, as
that means he doesn't
have to write a separate
admin user interface.
JOSH: That's less
than 50 lines of code
for a simple read-only
REST API that's
backed by a Google Sheet.
Nice.
Well, Max gave me
this US $1 bill.
He wonders, how much
could Slip Slap use
this service for that dollar?
MARTIN: Let's say Slip
Slap's internal systems hit
this service on average
once every 30 seconds, 24
hours a day, seven days a week.
This would fit comfortably
within the free tier
for Cloud Run, and they
wouldn't have to pay anything.
But what if they've used
up their free tier running
other Cloud Run services?
In that case, it would cost
Slip Slap a little under $1 US
to run the service
for one month.
JOSH: Not bad.
I'm also sure Max
is happy he doesn't
have to manage any servers.
MARTIN: Yeah, I think so.
Josh, Max didn't give you
another one of those lollipops,
by any chance?
[MUSIC PLAYING]